today
free to show their desperation now the
Russians have gone
no space for manners as they swarm the
Ukrainian relief truck
son give me an eight pack please I have
a walking stick she says
is recovering from months of trauma
under Russian occupation ended in a
lightning strike by Ukrainian troops
residents described how they felt when
salvation arrived
um
this place was a war zone a week ago
locals told us that Ukrainian forces
started attacking Russian positions
early on the 6th of September the city
was a key Target in the first days of
the counter-offensive and it took three
days until Commander said it was fully
under Ukrainian control
it's a victory the government is Keen to
show after days of restricting access to
the front line
the deputy defense minister said Ukraine
will recapture the whole of kharkiv
region
um
one of those weapons did this to a
school in a nearby Village
Russians had apparently used the place
as a headquarters but destroyed it after
they fled
evidence of the Hasty retreat
itude
it's not hard to see why there's such
fear
investigators say up to 300 people were
detained in these cells at the main
police station during the occupation
foreign
this Apparently one of the interrogation
rooms
now like so much of the country it's a
crime scene
Deborah Haynes Sky News better clear